[موسيقى]
نزول المطر في موسمه سهيل الوسم
المربعانيه الشبط وتتابع نزوله وكثره
الايام المشمسه هذه مقومات السنه الربيعيه
واول الربيع البادر ظهوره يتوقف على اول
مطره فاذا نزل المطر بلوسم فانه يظهر
سريعا لان الاجواء دافئه واذا نزل المطر
بالمربعانيه فانه يتاخر كثيرا لان الاجواء
بارده فالمربعنيه تكبل النبت ولا تجعله
يتنفس واذا امطرت السماء بسته امطار سينيه
خلال موسم سهيل والوسم والمربعانيه فانها
سنه ربيعيه وثلاثه امطار شبه ربيعيه واقل
من ذلك سنه مجدبه يعد الرياضه الحياه
والارض مجربه رزقا وفي البحر ذيل السحبي
مسحوب والرزقه وان لم يسع صاحبه حتما ولكن
شق المرئي
مكتوب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واهم الامطار الشتويه هي الامطار الوسميه
ومدتها 92 يوما فالعشرين يوما الاخيره من
موسم سهيل و52 يوم للوسم والعشرين يوما
الاولى من موسم المربعانيه هذه الفتره
مبيته لكل شيء حتى الفقع بين قوسين الكماه
واهم الامطار الصيفيه هي الامطار الهريسيه
وهي التي تاتي في اخر موسم الصيف وهي
المسببه لغزاره الامطار الشتويه ما هو الا
له سبب يبتدي منه ويتعبوا فتنه قلبي محجبه
وجهها بالحسن
منتقبه
[موسيقى]